How to handle case when the input context is higher than the input context window what
techniques can be used ok.
So, in general the context window defines the amount of takes that you can fit to the
LLM.
So, suppose your context window is of 50 words then you can fit maximum 50 words.
So, if you just fit it a document having 100 then rest of the 50 that is the last 50 they
will be truncated.
Now if you think that you have to fit the entire document at once one of the ideas could
be chunking; that means, you split the documents into two chunks of 50 50 and you pass them
one by one and then basically combine, cut in it or combine the information in some way
ok.
There are different ways of combining this, but what you are basically losing that if
you are basically fitting the entire document it will capture the entire context, but if
you have to split it into two then the first part cannot get the context information from
the second one that is the part we are losing.
So, in general that is why we are looking for the models having the larger context window
ok.
In top underscore catcher where likelihood weight comes from ok.
So, the likelihood weight comes from your probability distributions we have basically this language
models of this like we have this trigram or bigram models that you learn from the large
corpus.
So, that means if we are talking about the trigram so, like it is a continuation of three
words.
So, here we are checking that given the previous two words what is the probability of getting
the third word.
So, from a large corpus you gather this kind of probabilities that basically gives you
the likelihood that is what is the probability of appearing the next word given and that
probability we are using for the likelihood part that you are getting from the large corpus
of the vocabulary.
So, in top underscore K what if probability is very close or equal for two words.
So, it is basically equal you can go with the any of this ok and if it is not equal
you can go with the highest one generally this LLM they follow the greedy strategy in
the prompting.
So, whatever is the best it basically goes with that in the top underscore K.
Then you tokenize are LLMs considering the memory each token takes or just number of
tokens.
LLMs from like open AIs have limit for number of tokens for free and paid versions what
does it means technically again the number of tokens is basically related to a context
window.
So, if it is a free LLM in that case whatever the context window you cannot go beyond that.
So, rest of the tokens will be truncated now in open AIs they have their paid version.
So, basically in the free they basically fix max document length that you can give as input
that is why they put this constant and for the paid version; obviously, you have different
kind of schemes and based on that you can feed different kind of documents or basically
different document lengths.
But when you come to the free LLMs considering the memory each token takes or just the number
of tokens.
No, it does not consider the memory it consider the number of tokens that you are feeding
fine and thanks everyone.